Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
So today I have a very special
guest in Prith Banerjee, who is
the CTO of Ansys, somebody who I
am honoured to have on the
podcast because he truly is at
the position with the knowledge
to answer many of the questions
that I have been wondering
myself, but also asking many of
the guests on this podcast.
So to ask the CTO of one of
the largest and most important
CAE companies in the world was a
great honour.
And I hope it, it's good for you
as well to actually hear from,
you know, the person really at
the top of one of these big
companies.
And he's an amazing individual.
Actually, I, I watched some
videos of interviews with him
over the past few months and I
was so impressed by his
understanding of these emerging
areas, but also the way that he
was able to explain it in such a
simple way.
And you'll see him do this in
the interview today that
really shows that professor in
him.
And actually, let's talk about
what his background is.
Well, he was a professor for
more than 20 years, publishing
more than 350 papers,
supervising, you know, nearly 40
students.
So really had an amazing career
on its own as a professor in
Illinois, but then went off to
the startup world.
And we discussed a lot about
this need for people to
sometimes go from academia to
startups to, you know, fully
exploit the ideas they have.
But then he went into the
corporate world and became, you
know, CTO of companies like
ABB, HP Labs, Schneider Electric,
and now Ansys for the past six
years.
What an incredible individual to
have gone through those three
sort of main stages, I guess,
of, of, of the world that you
could be in, you know, academia,
startups and and industry.
It's amazing because it's also
one of those questions I've
often asked people on the show,
you know what, what do you think
about the differences?
So here's somebody who's, you
know, done it all and I really
wanted to ask him some of the
topics that I personally have
found interesting at, but I
think the community at large who
are into fluid dynamics and CFD
and HPC and AI are wondering.
So I, I put it to him as the CTO
of one of the biggest companies
in the world.
So we had a really deep and I
thought interesting discussion about
the role of machine learning and
artificial intelligence in CAE.
We've already dived into some of
the details, discussed at
length about foundational
models.
He came out with some really
interesting stuff and, and the
honesty that he had as CTO to
explain to his board that this
really is an important thing
that could even see the end of
the simulation market as we know
if they don't fully embrace it.
So we talked a lot about that.
We talked about quantum
computing, how that could be a
sign of things to come, some
changes which Ansys have been
working on.
We touched on, you know,
HPC, GPUs, but we also talked a
lot about the role of startups,
the roles of industry, what
startups should be trying to do.
And we talked some advice for
students, mid-career and
everybody about, you know, what
they could do to maybe come up
with the next amazing invention.
We touched on open-source,
closed-source and how we need to
work with academia.
And then, you know, we finally
ended on some advice, I guess,
to, to, to people and, and
really finished on what he is
quite an inspiring individual.
You know, he's written a book.
It's really amazing, The
Innovation Factory.
I can put the link on
YouTube if you're watching it.
And on that note, you know, if
you enjoy this, I really would
appreciate it if you did, you
know, like it, subscribe it.
The algorithms work that way.
If you if you like it but don't
interact, unfortunately, that
makes it harder for others to
find it.
So I don't often say this, but
I'll I'll say it once every few
episodes just because it would
help.
And also if you're watching this
on YouTube right now, just to
let you know, this is actually
also available in audio only on
Spotify and Apple and vice
versa.
If you're listening to this and
you weren't aware, there is also
a video version on YouTube.
So yeah, I, I, I really was so
pleased that he was willing to
speak.
I found this conversation so
interesting, and I hope you do
too.
So sit back and listen to this
interview with Prith Banerjee.
What was your journey to being
the CTO of one of the most
important and biggest simulation
companies in the world?
How did you how did you get
there?
I'm sure others would love to
have your position and your job.
So could you tell me a little
bit more about your career and
how you got to where you are
today?
So, so Neil, first of all, thank
you very much for inviting me to
this.
So I started my career in
academia.
I have got my PhD in electrical
and computer engineering from
the University of Illinois
Urbana-Champaign, and I started
as a professor at Urbana.
I spent the first dozen years
going through the ranks becoming
a full professor, and I was the
founding director of
Computational Science and
Engineering Program at UIUC.
Illinois has the National
Center for Supercomputing
Applications, a big place for
HPC.
And I used to do and my research
was on developing parallel
algorithms and parallel
compilers.
So I've always been working in
the HPC area.
So my last two years at
Illinois, I was a founding
director of computational
science and engineering, which
is the field of computing of
high performance computing using
HPC to drive sort of science and
engineering.
So computational physics,
computational chemistry,
computational electromagnetics,
all of those things.
And as it turns out, 30 years
later, I have landed up in
this job.
So that's sort of the
connection.
And then after Illinois, I went
to Northwestern.
I was then at the University of
Illinois Chicago.
So hardcore academic for about
20 plus years.
After that, I made a hard turn
into the corporate world.
I was head of HP Labs, and at
HP Labs I used to lead a lot of
work on on high performance
computing.
We used to build this really
super-duper high performance
servers, so a lot of cool work
there.
And then I became CTO at ABB, a
power and automation company
based in Zurich.
And then I became CTO at
Schneider Electric and another
power automation company based
in France.
About six and a half years ago I I joined
Ansys as the CTO.
So this is my third CTO job.
And what Ansys does is we are
the leading modeling and
simulation company in the world.
We take the world around us,
which is governed by the laws of
physics.
And we take that physics, which
is explained as second-order
partial differential equations.
And we solve those physics
through finite element methods,
finite volume methods using
things like Fluent, which is our
fluid solver, in things like
mechanical, which is our
structural code, in things like
HFSS, which is an
electromagnetic solver.
And my role as CTO is to look at
all these amazing products,
what is the future of
simulation?
What kind of technologies can be
used to drive future products?
And in my role as CTO, I look at
things like AI, machine
learning, right?
How does AI/ML improve
simulation?
HPC, how do you use HPC to
accelerate simulation?
How, what do you do with sort of
cloud, right?
What do you do with platforms or
digital engineering?
So that is I have the coolest
job in the company.
Yeah, looking at the future
future of simulation.
Yeah, which is why you're
absolutely perfect guest on this
podcast, because your job is
literally to answer, I guess
some of the questions that that
that people have.
But maybe I love the fact that
you have had such a great
academic career and going into
industry.
And it's one of the themes I
often ask people, you know,
academia or industry, what's the
benefits of both?
So what do you now, having done
both, what do you see as the
role of academia?
Where, where can academia help,
let's say, in advancing CAE and
where does industry need to do
it?
And where is the overlap?
Absolutely.
So so since you're asking a
career question, I I actually
bypassed one part of my career.
So I've actually had three
phases in my career.
I was in academia for 20 years,
but in between academia in the
large corporate world, I was in
the startup world.
I did two start-ups, One was
AccelChip; one was BINACHIP.
And these were companies started
out of technologies from the
university, from one from
Northwestern and one from the
University of Illinois.
And I did those while in
universities you can actually go
on sabbatical.
So I left, I took leave from the
university, did my first
startup, came back to the
university, the second startup
came back to the university.
So, and literally the reason I
went from the academic world to
the corporate world is because
of the startups, right?
So in the, So now let me ask you
the question.
In academia, what people do is
to solve fundamental problems,
right?
Really, I mean what I call
Horizon 3 futuristic research
problems, right?
Where we are trying to really
understand what is the absolute
the fundamentals of of, of
technology, right And he worked
with graduate students and I
have had in my 20-plus-year career
right in academia, I have had 37
PhD students and 40-plus master's
students with whom I have
published more than 350
technical papers in IEEE
conference in this and IEEE
Transactions of that and so on
so forth.
So that's the world of academia
where you're, you're
researching, you're discovering
new things and you're publishing
that work in the latest journals
and conferences, right?
It's all about creating new
knowledge and then transferring
that knowledge to brilliant
students, right?
So you are educating the
workforce in the next World,
right?
So in academia you have two
roles. One is invent, create
knowledge, right?
Discover knowledge which you
publish and then you train
students with the knowledge that
you have created, right?
Train undergraduate students,
graduate students and so on,
which are the workforces for all
of us, right, in academia and in
the corporate world to do.
But what academia does not do is
we don't build products, right?
And literally, Neil, the reason
I did the startups was I was
frustrated that I was doing all
this work, 350 papers, 10-plus
patents, doing all kinds of
stuff.
But nobody cared.
Nobody gave a damn right there
was because it was not showing
up in any product.
So when AccelChip was
actually created when I ended a
DARPA project called the MATCH
compiler and the DARPA PM said,
great, this is really awesome.
You should should transfer it to
a company.
So I came to the Bay Area,
talked to various companies and
say, would you like to use this
technology?
They said, absolutely, this looks so
good, just leave the the
software copy with us.
And I looked at them in the eye
and said there's no way they are
going to take this software like
the only way this really
commercialise if I were to do it
myself with my graduate
students.
So that's kind of why I started
the first company, AccelChip.
So startups, what they do is
they actually take a really new
idea, something that the world
has not seen before and get
laser focused on that idea and
they bring bring that that new
product to to the market, right.
And I did two of those startups
myself and then I came to the
large corporate world of HP, ABB
and so on, right?
But what I have found is the
large companies, they don't have
a single product like Ansys.
We have 70 products, right, in
simulation, right?
We have Ansys Mechanical, we
have LS-DYNA, we have Fluent, we
have this Twin Builder, all
kinds of products, right?
And the role of a large company is
to take these products and
evolve their products, right,
doing continuous innovation.
What features should I have in
the next release of Fluent, the
next release of, of mechanical
and so on?
So, but the innovation that
happens in in the corporate
world is more incremental,
right?
It is what I call Horizon one.
I have a product.
So I used to work at HP, right?
You make computers.
So, so next version of laptop,
right?
Is an incremental very
important, but something that
that you need to do.
We have Ansys Mechanical,
it's a finite element based
structural solver.
We are doing the next version,
right?
It's faster, it's a little
better convergence, better
meshing, but it's still the same
tool, right?
So that's what large companies
do academia, we invent new
things, right?
We are doing a hierarchical
octree mesh
representation, whatever and you
publish a paper and you're
getting a patent and so on.
But that is not a product.
What startups do is take that
work in academia and they
package it up into this really
brilliant disruptive innovation,
which I call Horizon 3
innovation, right?
The truly disruptive innovation
always happens in startups.
Large companies actually
struggle with with, with with
disruptive innovation.
In fact, Neil, I have done
broadcasts on this.
I have written a book called The
Innovation Factory, which your
readers may be interested in.
And the whole premise of this
book is how does a large company
like ABB or Schneider or or HP
or or Ansys, the companies that
have actually worked in the role
of CTO, right?
How do these companies try to
foster Horizon 3 disruptive
innovation, right?
Large companies doing disruptive
innovation and what I say in my
book is they they do it through
partnership with academia
because academia is where the
research in this future
directions is happening and with
startups and bring those so
academia and startups to this
thing in a concept called open
innovation.
And that is what I'm truly
passionate about.
So I know you asked me a
question about the difference
between academia and a large
world.
Academia does discovery of
knowledge Horizon 3, but they
don't actually make products
this disruptive innovation.
There are people like me who
leave academia and they build a
disruptive thing.
But in a concept of a startup, a
startup is laser focused on that
one product, right?
The world that has not seen
right, very disruptive, but
that's the only thing that they
do right.
So they're they're focused on
it.
And then they'll do the second
product and the third product.
Ultimately that will also become
a large company, at which point
it will stop doing Horizon 3
innovation.
It will become like the ABBs
of the world right until they
start.
They then start working with
with with other other startup
companies.
Yeah.
I really like how you put that,
that that's kind of what I was
getting at.
And I have to be honest,
particularly coming from Europe,
I think, and that it is slightly
changing now, there was nowhere
near the same startup culture.
And it's felt like you're an
academia.
You know, it was almost a dirty
word to try and commercialise
what you were doing.
You know, that's not pure
academia.
You know, you just publish.
And then there was the large
companies, you know, the Rolls-
Royces or whatever of the world
that I remember were funding it,
But it always felt like the
technology transfer wasn't the
same.
Now, having worked for a US
company and and being more
exposed to the Bay Area, I'm
kind of seeing how you're right.
This start-ups.
It seems like it's the it's the
mechanism in between that allows
these new ideas to to form.
But what are there any from your
time now?
I guess looking at start-ups,
but also having run a startup,
what sort of general advice
would you give to start-ups?
I know this is a very difficult
question to answer, but you
know, yeah, like would you, do
you go in with the mindset that
someone's going to buy you?
Do you go in the mindset that
you are going to be the next big
company?
You know, how do you think about
that?
Or advice you would give maybe
to start-ups trying to come up
with new ideas.
The way I would think about a
startup is if you're doing a
startup just to make money,
you've got the wrong motivation.
The motivation is really you are
trying to solve a problem that
the world has, right?
And you see no solution, right?
There's no existing solution
from the large companies, right?
I mean, you're trying to do this
fantastic computer that will
solve the world's problems,
right?
I mean, and the world doesn't
have that tool, that solution
today.
And you have you are maybe half
the time the startup founders
actually come from large
companies, right?
And they say they see a problem
and they say, you know what, I'm
going to solve this, right?
And typically in a large
company, the manager will allow
you to only work on things that
are incremental, right?
So you have, as I said, you are
working in HP or making laptops,
right?
If you say to HP, I want to build
a quantum computer, right?
You imagine we say go away, that
that's not what we do, right?
So but oftentimes these
problems come out and look at
you and say this needs to be
solved.
And you are, you are just, you
have this burning passion to
solve that problem.
And you sometimes your company
manager will allow you to do it
right.
Then you're lucky.
Then the company is actually
allowing you to do Horizon 3
innovation.
But 90% of the time you will not
be able to do it right.
And then you say, what, what
choice do I have?
You should then do a startup,
try to follow your passion,
follow your dreams and do it
right.
That's how most entrepreneurs
start startups, right?
The other way is for academia,
academic people, right?
And so literally startups come
from two ends.
Either it's an academic who has
solved a really hard problem and
say, OK, now we want to
commercialize it like me.
And again, I am just a very
small person, but there's so
many more famous people who came
from academia and some absolutely
wonderful companies, right?
And I mentioned them in my book.
And and then there's this
startup that happened from.
So I would say 80% of the
startup founders actually come
from the large corporate world,
right?
And then they have found a
problem solve it and then they
start one company, they start a
second company now with you
asked a question, what shop does
ultimately, yes, so you, you get
motivated by solving the world's
problems.
But of course there is a second
motivation.
I I would like to make some
money out of it, right.
So the way you pick a problem,
right, you should pick a problem
that has a large market, right?
And so how do you establish the
market?
That is the hardest thing for a
startup entrepreneur to do right
and.
So oftentimes you say, well,
what's the market for GPUs?
Well, you can take the look at,
look at NVIDIA and and AMD and
so on.
And it's OK, These are people
who are making GPUs, they are
selling this many GPUs.
And so the market for GPU is
this.
And if you are a new startup and
you do another GPU, you know
exactly what that market is,
right?
What's the market for, for
eyeglasses?
Eyeglasses.
You look at all the people who
are wearing eyeglasses.
You can say that, but suppose
you are a startup you have you
are inventing a device such as
blind men can see.
OK, that device does not exist.
You do a Google search of market
for device for blind men per se
is 0 because there is no product
in that area.
I mean, I'm just giving an
example.
Maybe today there is, but there
isn't, right?
So then you say, oh, the market
is 0, therefore it's a bad idea.
I should not do it because those
marketing things done by
companies like Gartner or
Dataquest, right?
They are only looking at at
markets where products exist,
right?
What's the market for the cloud?
It is $100 billion, right?
The market for cloud before Jeff
Bezos invented AWS was 0 right?
So right it it took a person of
Jeff's imagination says that the
market is this if I could build
it, right?
So then for that, that device
that blind men can see, right?
I'm the entrepreneur.
I'm trying to to find the
market.
I say, well, how many blind men
are there in the world, right,
that I know I have 10 billion
people on the planet.
I don't know, maybe 3 million
people are blind.
How much would they pay for it?
Well, I pay, I go to Lens-
Crafters and buy these glasses
for $200.00.
So at least I'm not blind.
But I'm paying something to
improve my vision.
So my at least I'll pay 200,
maybe 300.
So 300 times 100 million blind
people.
That's the $30 billion market.
That's how you size the market.
So you have a choice of making a
device such that blind men can
see.
The market is $30 billion versus a
chair with 9 legs, right?
And the market for that is only
$2.00.
You should pick the first one,
even though that is a harder
problem to work on because if
you're successful, you will
solve the world's problem.
And it's a large problem versus
inventing a chair with 9 legs,
which is a simple thing because
you know, I have a chair with
four legs.
It is easy to do with 9 legs,
but the market is only only two.
That's the simplistic way that I
can I can I can explain the
world of.
Startups. And I see that a little
bit with simulation is that it
is difficult probably in CFD
or CAE world to really
appreciate the difference I
guess between theoretical and
would anybody actually use it?
You know, like there's a
difference between saying, oh,
we could make CFD 10 times
faster, but even if it was 10
times faster, it doesn't mean
everybody's going to pick your
software because they may not
trust you.
They may prefer, you know, So I
guess this is where it
becomes even harder, doesn't it?
When you're, you know, the cloud
was such a massive new thing.
It's so clear.
I guess most start-ups are more
are not as revolutionary, you
know, and they're probably the
harder ones, aren't they?
Because there is a value, but
it's sort of harder to to figure
out.
And I guess maybe this leads
nicely because one of the things
that a lot of people have seen
is a huge growth now in the AI/ML
world, you know, obviously for
large language models.
But I think personally, what's
excited me is seeing how much of
this is now slowly moving into
the scientific world and the
potential impact it has on
accelerating traditional, you
know, CAE codes.
And I know you have your own
product as well, Ansys SimAI, but I
was just wanting to get maybe
some of your thoughts on where
you see the use of AI/ML today
short term and you know, what's
the what's the think big?
What's the art of the possible
that you think this could
become?
It's great.
That's a great question.
So let me explain my
thought, right, just by going in
the area of simulation itself,
right.
So I want to explain the
problem.
So when you're looking at
simulation of say, a fluids
problem, right, the problem is
formulated in the ideal world as
Navier–Stokes equations, right?
You have the, the governing
equations, you have energy
conservation, so on.
And those are second-order PDEs,
right?
So you can write those PDEs.
And when you went to college,
right?
You can take a very simple
differential equation, right?
Linear, whatever the simplest one
you could analytically solve,
right, is E to the power -2
whatever sum.
This is how the equations go,
right?
But in the practical world,
right, these problems have the
CAD geometries are so
complicated by the time you take
the CAD, define the boundary
conditions and so on, and you
have the Navier–Stokes equations
to solve it, right?
It is impossible to solve it
analytically.
So you have to solve it
numerically.
So you take those PDEs and you
discretise them, right?
So you do say finite elements,
right?
You take this whatever kind of
thing and you break it up into
1000 elements, right?
And in each, the finite element
method says on each element
those governing equations will
work.
So you solve it on that element
with the boundary conditions of
the other nodes that are next to
you and you keep iterating on
you.
And that's how all our numerical
methods work, right?
The trouble with these numerical
methods is the trade-off become
between accuracy and speed,
right?
So suppose you solve that
problem, the CFD with whatever,
with say 1000 elements, right?
And you get an accuracy which is
about 10% error, which may be
fine for you.
I said yeah, I like it, right?
And you solve that in an hour.
Say I don't like 10% error, I
wanted to be more accurate.
It is very easy in our world to
just instead of 1000 elements do
100,000 elements, right?
You do finer meshes and it will
be 1% error, right?
But then in instead of 1000
hours to run, it will take you
100,000 hours to run, right?
So the trade-off of accuracy and
speed in our world of CAE
simulation CFD is, is this
problem right, the accuracy
versus speed.
And we want both.
We want both accuracy and speed.
And then furthermore, the third
thing is these things are so
complicated in terms of
convergence.
Sometimes you do these crazy
things with the meshing, it
doesn't converge.
So wow, my God, I didn't
converge.
Oh, it didn't converge because of
this.
I should use Mosaic meshing.
I should use tet meshing.
So there are these zillion tools
that I have at my disposal and
the the CAE analyst is using all
of these things and sometimes it
works, sometimes it doesn't.
So it's not that easy to use.
Imagine a tool out there that'll
say, hey, me, run this thing for
a a external aerodynamics of a
Boeing 777 airplane, right?
You just give it in English and
automatically it sets the
settings for STAR-CCM+ or or
Exa from Dassault or Fluent.
It just does it like that's the
ultimate Holy Grail.
So in our world, the problem is
you have to go be accurate.
You have to be fast, it has to
be easy to use and converge all
the time.
That is the Holy Grail.
So in my role as CTO, I look at
all the solvers, I say how can I
get to that current state to
make it more accurate, faster,
easy to use and so on, right.
So I have, one of the things is
I have a pillar on numerical
methods and we are just with
advanced numerical methods,
right?
We are doing without using high
performance computing, without
using AI/ML.
I'm trying to make it faster,
accurate, for example doing
better meshing, for example
using higher order methods,
right?
How about using hierarchical
octree?
So it's a sequential algorithm,
but just using smart things in
the numerical method itself you
make it faster, easy to use,
converge all the time and so on.
The second pillar is HPC, right?
I mean, again, you worked at
AWS and you have all those high
performance computing, right?
So we have we, we, we take, we,
we take an algorithm and we
parallelise it, put it on 100
processors using shared memory
or message passing with
distributed sort of data
decomposition, all with GPUs.
So there are all these different
things basically.
But this is what I call brute
force acceleration, right?
I have a job that I have decided
that I will use 1,000,000
elements, right?
So because of accuracy I have
and it's taking me 1000 hours to
run.
If I had 100 processors, the
best I can get is get 100-times
speedup and run it in 10 hours,
right?
So within that I use shared
memory message passing GPUs XYZ
and now we are looking at
quantum computing also to speed
things up, right?
But that's what I call brute
force parallelism, right?
The third pillar that we have is
AI/ML, which is sort of your
question.
So AI/ML has been used in a
variety of fields, but we and it
has been used in, as you know,
for, for recommendation engines
for this and so on.
Hey, which restaurant should I
go to?
It's wonderful for those things,
right?
Or ChatGPT allowing you to
write wonderful poetry and text.
But the question that we asked
is, can AI/ML be applied to
numerical-method simulation,
right?
And that's when I joined the
company six years ago, my CEO
said, what do you want to work
on?
I said, I want to work on AI.
And the early work on AI that we
did was to say, OK, let's take a
black box solver like Fluent
which is a fluid solver,
right?
Give it an initial condition,
boundary condition and you get
the output.
And with this input and output
you train an AI model, right?
And you see you have this new six-
stage neural network, right?
And you are you have these
weights of the neural networks.
You don't know what the weights
are.
So you start with some random
weights with some random weights
on the neurons, right?
You, you here is an input, here
is the output.
So with random weights you will
predict an output which will be
completely wrong.
There is an error at the output.
You say now that there is an
error.
How do I minimize the error?
I do backpropagation to adjust
the weights of neural networks
so that my error is zero for this
input output combination.
Then I give it a second input
with a different boundary
condition, different whatever,
and with now the previous set of
weights.
I run it, I get a predicted
output.
I have a new output from Fluent.
Again there is an error.
I said, oh, I need to fix the
error.
So I do backpropagation to
change the weights again.
And then I do the third input
with the first two set of
weights and my third input.
I keep iterating.
After about 100–200 cases, I
kind of get, I converge on the
set of weights on the neural
network, right?
And within that there's all
kinds of there's choices, right?
Should I have a six-stage
network?
Should I have a eight-stage
How many?
What's the depth?
What's the depth, right?
And that ties to the parameter
size of your, of your network,
right?
But assuming you have done all
that, right, that's what SimAI
does.
So SimAI is a platform which
allows a customer to take their
problem their sets of designs.
Use our tool Fluent for fluid
dynamics or Ansys Mechanical for
structures or HFSS for
electromagnetics.
And you, Mr. Customer, use SimAI
platform to train the AI models
on your problem and then train
it for the 1st 100 designs that
you have and the 101st design
instead of taking 100 hours,
it will run in a minute.
That's the value proposition.
Now the AI is only as good as
the data you train it with,
right?
So if you train it with this
picture of you have an SUV,
right?
You, you train it with this SUV
from Toyota, there are 10
different versions of
Highlander, the, the, the
4Runner, the RAV4 or
whatever.
And then also the SUVs from,
from Hyundai and the SUVs from
Ford.
So you are training it with
SUVs, it learns, then you give
it an airplane.
I have not seen this before.
And AI is only good as the data
it has been trained on.
But you may say, oh, therefore
it's not, not not useful.
It is actually useful because if
you work for a company like
Airbus, right, you're making
airplanes or Boeing, you're
making airplanes.
You're not going to go from one
airplane to tomorrow doing a
submarine, right?
So you're actually doing only
airplanes.
So it actually works.
There is value in subtle
variations and that's what
designers do, right?
There have been thousands of
designs of slightly different
airplanes or slightly different
cars and so on.
So there is value in SimAI.
But then you ask the question,
right, So where is the future?
The future is foundational
models for AI where the customer
will not have to train any set
of things.
There is no need for a SimAI
platform.
We, Ansys, will take the world
of physics, of fluids around us
and we'll train it and that is
what we will.
So we will train the AI, just
like ChatGPT has trained all the
words in the English language,
right?
And has learned how to speak,
how to write poetry.
The grand vision of AI with
foundational models for physics
is to do that.
It is an incredibly hard
problem, but that's what we are
working on.
But you, that's interesting
because I've often had this
debate on the commercial or the
economics of that.
As in, if you are a car company,
you probably have your own cars.
Like you said, it's quite
incremental and you'll train,
you could train using your own
data that is proprietary to you.
And you, you would have assumed
that the model you would train
would be as accurate as possible
because it's your cars and your,
your, your iterations.
Same if you're an aircraft
designer.
I guess what you're alluding to
is if your company or another
company could run their own
simulations of all of these
different things and then train
a massive model, will that model
be more accurate than the model
that the car company has trained
themselves?
And.
Yes, yes, and and and here's
why.
I'll go back to the Google
example.
Like Google search is so good
because it's a free tool, right?
You and I type things on Google
and based on it, they are
creating this massive database,
right?
This PageRank algorithms of
this, tied to that and so on.
And based on I'm clicking this,
right, gives you the list
of 100 things, and you click
this.
And the more you click, that is
a more important thing, right?
And so if Google were to be only
limited to the searches that
Prith and Neil only did, that's
the only data they looked at,
the search would not be as good.
The reason Google is good is
because they're looking at the
10 billion people on the planet
banging on our, on our
keyboards, right, for free.
They, they, we think it is a
free thing.
They're not paying us to give
us, give them the data, right?
They're using all our
information to make the search
be better.
So in exchange for us getting a
free tool, we are giving Google
back the knowledge in our head
that after I type who is Neil
Ashton from AWS, right?
That somebody in the world is
actually interested in the
question of who is Neil Ashton
from AWS?
And the other question is who is
Prith Banerjee from Ansys, right?
That is knowledge that is being
captured by Google.
So now my knowledge is right.
Suppose I went to train it only
on Airbus designs, right?
Think of it as the Google
search for only people within
Airbus typing their searches
versus letting the searches go
to all engineering companies,
right?
To Airbus and Boeing and Pratt &
Whitney and GE, it will be
clearly richer.
Yeah.
That's the value now to make it
happen, right?
So, so I'll, I'll anticipate the
question, right.
So where do you get the data
from, right?
So this is something I'm
actually thinking of, right?
So to build these foundational
models, I will have to get all
the CAD files from Airbus and
all the CAD files from Boeing.
Will Boeing and Airbus be
willing to give it to us?
And this is the whole thing
about Google, right?
I just give it.
The reason I give the Google
example is they created a
business model which was free,
perceived free, but in exchange
for free they are sucking in their
stuff, right?
So can I create a model which is
an opt-in model where all Ansys
customers would opt to give
their data in an anonymised way
to Ansys to collect the data,
run all those things for example
on the AWS cloud, right?
And the cloud is a great way to
train all these models because
if it is on-prem, you actually
cannot have access to it.
But if you are going on the
cloud, if every customer, if all
CAD designs are done on the
cloud, right, it is actually
possible.
All you need is for Airbus and
Boeing and Ford and GM to say
you can train the model.
Just don't attribute it to Ford.
Yeah, that's.
So now we are getting into
policy-type things.
So it is possible.
And so if if that were to
happen, it would be more
accurate than the Airbus
specific result that is the long
answer to that question.
Yeah, no, no.
And I think this is actually
something that Max Welling, when
I spoke with him, he brought up
which was the incentivizing
people to share data, you know,
exactly, you know, that having
some mechanism where either they
get paid for it or they get
something in return, something
that will allow them to overcome
the barrier.
The, the sort of traditional
position of this is our data.
I'm not going to, you know, let
anybody else use it to the point
where they see a benefit from
doing it.
I guess the technology piece is
the making it anonymous.
You know, that's probably the
challenging bit is to sort of
figure out how to do it.
But I guess this is not limited
to simulation.
This is a broader question,
isn't it, to and?
And for example, people are now
suing DALL-E right for hey, you,
you are generating an image based
on my I'm an artist.
I'm I'm whatever, right?
I'm Prith Banerjee.
I've written a beautiful
picture, right?
And you took that picture into
DALL-E and now you generate a new
picture, right, based on its
hidden knowledge.
That's not fair if Prith
Banerjee were to say I will
give 10 of my pictures to DALL-E
or 10 of my poems to OpenAI
right and I get one cent for
everything that I give every
token I give to contribute to
this thing, I get one cent.
Hey, I am I incentivised in that
case, I will not sue DALL-E.
So my thing is, I think the
whole world of GenAI, all the
governance mechanism, so on, is
that people getting sued because
they feel like their
intellectual property is not
getting recognized, right?
Why do people have patents?
Well, they have patents so that
they can have royalties based on
the patents, right?
That royalties based on the
patent, which is this big thing
in the world of AI.
You have to figure it out how to
take that big thing into small,
small chunks and to figure
a royalty of 1 cent per pixel,
right?
Literally.
I mean, the world will actually
go in that area.
I I think the world will really
figure out it's governance and
fairness so that everybody wins.
Yeah.
No, no, I, I think that's a
really good analogy.
I, I, I and I agree with you.
I think if the data maybe this
leads to the other one because
often the question is around
data-driven versus physics-
driven with the logic being that
you know, we operate in a
scientific world, we should
include physics in the models.
But often the argument is we
need to include physics because
we don't have enough data.
And I have followed the progress
of you know physics-informed
etcetera.
But what struck me is to, to my
knowledge anyway, most of the
successful examples in the
public domain have been with
data-driven approaches typically
and not so much from the
theoretically better, but often
practically not as convenient.
So do you think that is just
because it's harder and it will
take more time to sort of
develop the more physics-
informed, physics-inspired, you
know, how much do you think that
is a needed science step to
really overcome the data
challenge and the generalization
challenge when it comes to AI
for, you know, computer-aided
engineering?
That is a great question
actually.
And the answer is there is not
enough research that has
happened.
There's more research that has
happened in the data world,
right?
Purely data-driven method is
more general.
That's the advantage, right?
And and you don't need anything,
just do do the data and you do
your stuff, right.
But it requires enormous amount
of data, right to do the right
level of accuracy for the models
where physics-informed gets you
is so so I mean, I just I know
you know this, but to your
readers, I will give you a very
simple explanation, right?
So suppose you are trying to
look at fluids data, right?
And you are trying to put it
into an AI model for fluids,
right?
You will take the the fluids
data here is this velocity,
pressure, etcetera, temperature
and so on.
And this is the distribution,
right?
And you think the whole thing is
is random.
It is not because the fluids
physics says there is Navier
Stokes equation, there is energy
conservation, all the stuff that
you know from a physics point of
view.
So the data will not be
completely uncorrelated.
The data is actually going to be
this thing with this turbulence
will be constrained to only this
set of things, right?
So if the, if there are three
things here you are, you are
measuring, right?
If it is, if you know these two
points, you can deduce the third
point.
It is actually not an
independent variable, right?
That's the, the, the, the thing
about statistics, right?
You think not all the things are
going to be independent.
So the pure data-driven approach
assumes everything is
independent and it's not.
So if you can insert the
knowledge of the physics, you
can constrain.
You say you don't have to search
for millions of data points, you
can do it with only 1000 data
points.
That's the power of physics-
informed, right?
And the work was, as you know,
done by I mean, Karniadakis—
George Karniadakis— at Brown
University, and we did a lot of
work at Ansys we've done a
lot of work at NVIDIA on these
things.
The trouble is when we started
doing the physics-informed to
incorporate the physics, the
computation needed in this, we
have not quite figured that out,
right?
And then then people went
towards graph neural networks
and then NVIDIA did the work on
FNO.
So I saw this this lot of
research being done and
somewhere in there in the Holy
Grail is foundational models.
And once that thing is invented
is like the Einstein theory of
relativity, the the universal
thing, something like this will
happen where we'll merge the
areas of numerical methods and
AI.
And that I have told my board is
when the whole market for Ansys
will completely collapse because
we have the last 50 years we
have worked on, on the fact that
it's all numerical methods and
so on, right?
Numerical methods will no longer
be needed.
It will all be done with AI,
with the accuracy and the speed
much, much better than than
numerical methods.
But we're not there yet.
That's where the research is
needed.
And that actually brings me on
to the point then of how, how
can we enable that research to
happen.
As you said yourself, a very
large enterprise will struggle
to dedicate resources to
fundamental problems because of
the pressures of headcount, of
incremental product improvement.
A start up can do that, but
they're not, they have pressure
from their VCs to actually
deliver something within a, you
know, relatively small amount of
time usually.
So it falls down to academia.
But if, let's say foundational
models is, as you rightly say,
could be a, you know, Eureka
moment, you know, a massive
moment for the field.
The bit that I've noticed is
data, you know, you could
incentivize people to give you
data through, you know, and CIS
and, and mechanisms.
But I wonder, therefore, what's
your opinion of the open source
versus closed source?
You know, how much should we be
trying to create some open
source data that's to help the
academia, but not do too much
that you give all your IP away
and you know, you, you, you lose
an advantage.
So where does that balance?
That is a great point.
In fact, let me tell you, the
reason that the AI world has
worked so fast is because of
open source, right?
You have things like TensorFlow
and PyTorch, these are absolutely
open source ways of doing neural
networks, right?
I mean, you, they could have
like Google and so on could have
kept all of those and Facebook
could have kept it completely
closed, right?
And then the world wouldn't have
done all this kind of stuff,
right?
NVIDIA opened up CUDA, right?
So CUDA became sort of not, and
the code is not open.
So, but they have open
framework, right?
So the combination of open
source things like CUDA, open
source things like PyTorch and
TensorFlow, etcetera, and open
source models for the data like
ImageNet and all those things
that are out there, right?
It has accelerated the pace of
innovation in the world of AI,
unlike other fields like in the
world of numerical methods, we
at Ansys know something, Dassault
knows something.
Siemens knows something and we don't sort of
share stuff, right.
So there's a paper they'll come
from CMU or Stanford, some
wonderful people and we, we say,
ah, but they are working on, on
trivial toy problems.
They cannot work on Ansys, but
Ansys will not give those tough
problems that did not happen in
the AI world, that did not
happen in the MapReduce world,
in the MapReduce world, right?
The MapReduce thing was
actually openly given away,
right?
Open source by both Google and
and Yahoo.
Now why did they do that?
That MapReduce framework is a
framework that Google needs to
improve their searches, right?
So it was a brilliant business
move for them to open-source Map-
Reduce to the world, right where
the smartest graduate students
at MIT and Oxford and and CMU,
they all work to improve Map-
Reduce and it's open source.
So all the innovations that
coming from the the open
source world academic world,
Google could put in and make the
search even better, right?
They did not say here is a
search algorithm that we open
source that they took a core
part of their search algorithm
which they are making money off,
right, with ads.
So I thought that was an
absolute brilliant strategy.
Linux is another brilliant
strategy, right, for for
advancing operating systems,
right?
Which is so we have to actually
learn.
So the in our world of CAE
simulation, right, there is
obviously one code called
OpenFOAM.
Since you know, fluids, you know
OpenFOAM, right?
So it's open source, actually
OpenFOAM plus OpenAI.
I mean sort of is sort of where
I think things will happen.
But for that you also need that
data for the CAD models, right?
And so just like ImageNet has
created this thing for 2D and 3D
images, we need in this area
some work on 3D geometries of
all kinds of things, on gears
and this and and propellers and
airplanes and so on.
If you can do that, I think that
will advance the
state-of-the-art.
Yeah.
And we, you know, we, we
ourselves published a couple of
datasets: DrivAerML and
AhmedML.
That I I am aware so.
The which have helped a little
bit, but I.
Not at the level of ImageNet,
not at the level of of.
Exactly.
But the the other bit that I
always and maybe I just need to
get my brain around this, which
is if you're training like a
large language model, the text
and the data that you scrape up
the Internet is in some ways
it's sort of the ground truth.
Yes, someone has written it, but
it isn't a simulation, right?
It is someone writing it.
If you transfer now to, let's
say CFD, I could run simulations
of thousands of cars and planes,
but the model will only, well,
this is my question.
Using, let's say, just a
standard approach, it's only
going to learn the equivalent
simulation settings if it's a
RANS approach or an LES
approach, or a mesh that is
coarse or fine.
If I do all my simulations with
a RANS, the model's going to
learn.
So does that mean you have a
foundational model of this
simulation approach and then you
have another foundational model?
Or is there some way?
Or or you have to curate your
data so that you take 10% of the
data from RANS, 10% data from
LES, 10% data from DNS.
That would be the real
foundational model.
So getting back to your issue,
right?
And so the reason, so I'm glad
you asked this question because
with large language models for
words as tokens, you are
absolutely right.
They have scraped all the words
from all the books that people
have written, right?
Of course, they are not giving
the royalty back to the people
who have written those things,
right, Pop chap, right.
They have not generated those.
Suppose a next version of Chat-
GPT is take ChatGPT to generate
all those texts, right?
And then you feed it, that would
be what your problem would be,
right?
So and there and, and DALL-E has
taken the same approach of
taking all the images on the
Internet and use those images to
program DALL-E, right?
And Sora has done the same thing
for for videos, right?
So in our world to do the
foundational models, it has to
be the 3D fields.
Now you can actually go and
measure 3D fields, right?
You you take a car right Google
Waymo those cars have videos
right.
So imagine you you sensorise
your car to measure the fluid
flow at every small microsecond
or micro whatever millimeter of
your car right.
That is an actual measurement.
I mean this is the air how the
airflow actually happened on the
on the car right that you have
to take thousands of cars
millions of cars and so on.
It's just ridiculous right.
So what I am saying what I have
told my board is we Ansys will
create the synthetic data
through simulation right of all
the fluids model.
But you are absolutely right, we
Ansys Fluent is RANS simulation.
So it will not be generating the
LES.
So we will also have to do the
LES and the DNS and for external
fluid and for for cars and
trucks and so on.
So only if you do all of that
will be a true foundational
model, which is why if ChatGPT
took six months and 1.8 trillion
parameters, in our world, it is
probably a billion trillion
parameter.
I don't even know what the size
of the model is, but it is
possible.
I absolutely it is possible and
we'll eventually get there.
Yeah, it is.
It is so fascinating, isn't it?
Because that it would be a
transformational change.
Like you say, you're right to
tell your board that it's the
honest truth that the tradition
of, you know, running your own
simulations, if the model was
accurate enough and you know,
there's a big if I guess on
that, it would certainly become
a very widely, it would disrupt
the market, that's for sure in
a, in a big, big way.
Let me.
Let me make this statement to
your readers.
I know you know this, but the
whole world of physics, right?
When Newton observed an apple,
he dropped it and it fell down
and he derived something else,
right?
Just by a bunch of observations
in the real world.
That data that he fed into his
engine right determined the law
which is force equals mass times
acceleration which is a
differential equation right.
He deduced the law of gravity by
observations.
It is therefore possible to
observe the world around us and
actually we have got work going
on with Google DeepMind right.
DeepMind is using the Ansys
tools to observe the physics and
learn the physics.
So that imagine you're trying to
balance a long pen on your head,
right?
Yeah, I'm sure when you're a
kid, you did that and you're
balancing, right.
When you ball, the thing goes on
the other side.
You you move your hand, right.
So they have actually taken that
as an example to use Ansys
Mechanical to model the world of
structures, right?
And just by say and thereby
train the Google DeepMind
has trained the robot arm to do
the balancing of this by
learning the physics.
So it is possible and that is
how I think foundational models
will work because Isaac Newton
generated the physics model of
force equals mass times
acceleration by looking at the
data.
By observing the data, AI is
going to observe the physics
around us and train the physics
models.
Every one of those equations can
be deduced.
Navier–Stokes equations can be
reverse engineered by AI.
And that would be, it's
interesting to bring up the
robotics angle to that, because
I guess this is the, the, the
bigger picture, isn't it the
sort of future of manufacturing,
the future of robotics?
You know, CAE, you don't just
simulate for the sake of it, do
you?
You simulate it to do something.
And so you're right, there is a
much, you know, broader, broader
picture around.
However, one thing a sort of
counter example to that, I
guess, which goes back to your,
well, not a counter example, but
another way of thinking about
it.
You said right at the beginning,
accuracy and speed or cost, It's
true that all engineering
companies are so, you know,
focused on that, aren't they?
Accuracy, speed, cost.
So if your traditional
simulation could be fast enough
and cheap enough, you don't
necessarily need AI, do you?
That could be a normal approach.
So I was just wondering the
quantum piece, everybody brings
this up and I would love to get
your perspective on how
realistic is it and of what
parts of you think that CAE
could speed up the quantum side
of things?
Could could quantum speed up the
CAE side of things?
Or do you see it still as being
too niche and yeah, not?
No, no, it's a great question.
And actually in my CTO office,
so the the first thing I did in
my CTO office was to work on AI
and now I've got now that that's
AI thing is sort of not solved,
but at least we have some
products out in this area,
right?
We have started working on
quantum for exactly that reason.
And the the beauty of quantum is
it is a potential for
exponential speedups, right?
Because if you have N qubits,
your speed, your, your, your
runtime, your, your speed up is
2ᴺ, right?
And so as you typically quantum
computing algorithms have been
used on problems that are sort
of NP-complete to begin with,
right, exponential problems like
materials discovery, your
optimisation and travelling
salesman and so on.
And you would think that in our
world, right our our problems
are polynomial: N cubed.
Except that N is huge, N is a
million million cubed is a large
number, right?
So if you can throw a 2 to the
power P kind of exponential
capacity to solve a polynomial
problem order N cubed where N is
very large, yes there are
benefits.
So we are looking at ways these
algorithms called the HHL
algorithm that you may have
heard of that can take a because
in all our things like we
ultimately we will take our PDEs
and and make it into some Ax
= b, some matrix vector.
So you are trying to solve some
linear system equations.
Turns out that quantum computers
can solve linear systems of
equations like with exponential
speed up.
So we are looking into those
kind of methods at Ansys.
It is not going to be next year.
It'll not be two years, but
definitely within 10 years we'll
see quantum computing
accelerating CAE simulation.
And that'll be interesting.
It's almost like you never quite clear
what technology will be the one
that transforms.
You know, the I know it's not a
great analogy, but you don't
remember 3D glasses.
The televisions came out and
everyone thought that would be
it.
We'll all wear 3D glasses.
And at least to my knowledge, it
sort of died away because in
reality, nobody wants to put
those on.
Now maybe there's a future one,
you know, with the Apple vision,
etcetera.
But it's amazing how resilient
we have been to watching a
normal TV, even with all the
sort of technology changes.
So it does often make me wonder,
is it ML, is it quantum?
You know will one of them.
And actually this quantum ML
people are now working on
quantum machine learning.
So, so, so it is this
combination of things that means
to your broader question, what I
I would say is Ansys is now a
company of about 2 1/2 billion
dollars, right?
And our software originated from
CAE simulation written in Fortran
in 1970, right?
But then as newer technologies
like HPC came in, we took that
Fortran code and said, OK, let's
put it on a shared memory and
with this directive, parallelise
it.
And then the GPUs came in, well,
with this directive, make it run
on CUDA and so on.
So it has been always
retrofitting a piece of thing.
And somehow we have OK, now
let's work with this.
And now the AI/ML came in and
let's do it with with
TensorFlow.
And now let this cloud came in.
Let's try to make it on the
cloud, right?
What if, and this is sort of a
thought experiment.
I, I asked of my technology, I
said, what if you knew that you
have access to quantum, to AI/ML,
to cloud, to GPUs, all of those
technologies and you to start
writing Ansys Mechanical, How
would you write it?
You would definitely and you
have languages like Julia and
Python And so on, right?
Would you write it in Fortran
with the linear algebra? Not at all
right.
And this is sort of the
advantage that startups have.
A startup has no legacy.
This is what how I try to
motivate people.
I said if you are a startup, you
have the latest widgets, right
With with AR, VR, IoTI don't know
what it is right.
Put all of that in the blender
and out will come something that
a large company like Ansys has
not had the luxury of doing
right.
That's the power of the Horizon
3.
And that that's a great sort of
circle back to our original
point that essentially I think
what you're saying is you want
the startups to take that
challenge to say, I want to
start from scratch.
Prove to me, Ansys, that a new
written code using the latest
technology right now could be,
you know, exponentially better
than retrofitting another code.
And that is what would make a
startup attractive to you.
That's what would change the
market.
That's what would do it.
And it's only really a startup.
And the business model is the
following, right?
Oftentimes I am asked, at
Ansys, hey, you are doing this
right with AI/ML, why are you
doing this?
Is you'll kill your cash cow,
right?
Because if with AI you know
things run 100 times faster,
it's not good for the Ansys
Mechanical business or fluid
business, right?
But the response is if I don't
do it myself, a startup would do
it and destroy me anyway.
So I might as well do it myself,
right.
So it is like the classic case
of Kodak.
They actually knew of digital
printing.
It's not like those guys are
stupid.
They actually know digital
thing.
But the cash cow from analog was
so good that they did not want
to disrupt it, right?
Motorola knew about digital
phones, but they, they, they
were afraid of it, right?
So it's always the innovator's
dilemma, right?
I have a cash cow business,
right?
Should I do it?
And so companies like Apple
where Steve Jobs said the iPhone
is going to disrupt iPod, but I
would rather disrupt iPod myself
than be disrupted with somebody
else.
And whereas a startup has got
nothing to lose, right?
They're starting with zero
revenue, right?
So that's the advantage of a
startup.
And what I write in my book is
therefore companies like Ansys,
like Kodak, like Motorola need
to work with the digital
printers, the digital phones,
the digital, the quantum or AI-based
simulation and embrace them and
bring them into your thing,
right?
That's the way a company like
Ansys can actually stay on top
of Horizon 3 Innovations, right?
Yeah.
And I think that's probably
where I think that, you know,
Jeff Bezos with his original
Amazon leadership principles,
the one of customer obsession
makes sense if you just focus on
what, what would a customer want
that typically always works.
And that always works.
That always.
And that has been my
defining philosophy.
Yeah.
Well, maybe to close out, I
would love just to get some of
your, you know, summarised
advice.
I guess there's people listening
to this who are maybe, you know,
coming to the end of their PhDs,
They're in industry.
They have ideas.
What would be your if you had to
summarize?
What have helped you to get to
such an illustrious position
where, where you are now?
How What advice would you give
to people at the end of this to
motivate them in their in their
careers?
So, so the motivational thing is
exactly what I kind of covered
in the last minute, right?
That they have to just in fact,
in my book, I talk about the
digital technology that we have
today, right?
I talk about quantum, I talk
about AI, talk about IoT, talk
about platforms, all the stuff
that is there, right?
So here is a kid graduating with
a PhD in 2024.
When I graduated with a PhD in
1984, forty years ago, I didn't
have those things, right?
So you guys have so much more
exciting technology at your
disposal, right?
You have to figure out to solve
a world's problem of simulation
or base or whatever, I mean
healthcare or, or, or whatever
problem, right?
Try to figure out the
combination of quantum plus ML
plus cloud plus whatever, right?
I mean, how can I solve the
world's problem, right?
You start with a problem that
you're going to solve, right?
And you have a choice.
You could either work in a large
company and just join that and
run on that treadmill and, and
you'll be guaranteed $100,000–
$200,000 salary.
You have a home, you, you, you
whatever, right?
Or you are passionate.
You see, I could take a risk do
do something interesting.
And, and my son who graduated
from Berkeley, he actually chose
the path of the startup, right?
I mean, he, he, he could have
joined many.
He had a computer science degree
from Berkeley.
He could have interviewed, he
had interviewed at all the large
companies in the Bay Area, but
he chose to do a startup and
he's working on a startup in the
healthcare area.
And I, I, I wish him all the
luck, right?
And, and so he has taken a risk.
He has taken a much less
compensation in, during the
years of a startup with the hope
of transforming the world in
this healthcare startup called
Sempre Health that he's doing
right along with his wife,
Anurati.
So, so that is the the message.
I would like to end it with
that.
Follow your passion.
You have to take some risks in
life, right?
It is not easy, the life of
startup, but if it is
successful, you will transform
the world and will transform
your personal financial
situation.
But you shouldn't do a startup
for the financial.
You should do the startup
because you really want to solve
a really hard problem that the
world doesn't know how to solve
using the latest technologies
that you have.
And people have not figured out
how to combine quantum plus AI
plus HPC plus cloud plus IoT,
right?
And you are the first guy who
did it, right?
It's that interdisciplinary
thing.
The ability to assimilate is
what is unique in the startup.
So if take a problem that is
really hard and solve it with
the gadgets that you have today,
which Prith Banerjee in 1984
did not have access to, you guys
in 2024 have so much more to
work on.
Now that that's great advice and
that, yeah, the I agree the the
passion you need to have, it's a
bit like doing a PhD.
There's no point in doing a PhD
just for the sake of it, or
you'll fail, or you'll.
You can still attacking my
voice, right?
I I.
Thank.
You very much for inviting me
for for the podcast.
I really, really enjoyed it.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
This has been great.
Ansys is very lucky to have you
as their CTO, so thank you
again.
Thank you, Neil.